[Music]
how's it going rose look Ruben is there
are you doing Ruben I totally missed
okay [ __ ] Ruben Jesus Christ die like
you're supposed to like I'm in shop
heaven top top top top top top drugs
chop chop chop chop chop chop
nothing chop chop chop chop I feel like
I've been here before
top top top top top top top top hey my
drugs with my dress women good cop tough
tough tough tough tough tough tough
tough tough tough tough tough tough
tough good that doesn't sound where
again top top top top top top top top
all right
after that the Tata Tata Tata to the top
come on come on bro
[Applause]
just sides boy jumps on oh I don't care
he's pretending it sounds like I'm I
don't know I don't know I'm offline I've
seen now anyway
ha and no battery I okay as long as
there's no dark part hey haven't I been
here all right seriously recognize this
place indoors
why didn't I end it at some other spot
person yeah oh oh oh oh my apologies
okay let's go here without no battery or
life wait this is not that idea that I
think I'm stuck
actually no I'm never stuck ever okay
maybe a little
what about here oh I can't say anything
out it's killing me I died I knew that
what's gonna happen question is why the
[ __ ] don't go there
my car no sales the thing is I all right
[ __ ] you ah ah ah never kill Mesa crazy
oh you go here oh sweet alright I got it
waiting this is where I came from oh
yeah I got the keys now now I remember I
remember new you click that you take out
the keys have a bus Boop alright
blah stop fighting oh [ __ ] okay
okay we're good
you still fall okay we're good you lost
the track of where I'm going
that's cool allowing this cool I'm a
cold person yes indeed
that's what my mama tells me all the
time okay there's someone here isn't it
my girl
Oh what the [ __ ] it where's Annabelle
okay ah why would ya what's wrong with
your head come ah let's watch peopie die
a million times yeah alright I need a
better gun do I have a gun yeah I don't
have a gun okay let's just run past that
guy alright alright
it should be a gun in here top top top
that touch a touch top alright let's
kill him come on brah what bra
we're z-ro put chimera
if one hit and I'm dead so I can't like
hahahaha I did that easily okay let's go
down elevator hopefully it's the right
place to go I doubt it I got it a lot
hey is it stuck stop moving can you see
did I break down oh there we go
there we go you guys got a shop it's top
top top dub dub dub dub dub dub dub dub
dub dub top top top top top it up I got
damn it
I'm so screwed alright we can be
relevant Oh
bounce it ah why would the I yeah is
that going to well I mean of course it
gonna support it I am a super Mouth
football ma I just don't understand
where I left the keys or whatever all
right let's just go [ __ ] everything and
just run this hope it isn't following me
top top top top top top top drugs F
[ __ ] six hmm go in here ah my
with it there that chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop topped up alright we good
[ __ ] that guy right that [ __ ]
elevator
alright forget now when this guy comes
I'm gonna shoot him in the face
he's a hey hi patty I waited for you I'm
so pumped how pumped to see you I'm
pumped to see you too [ __ ] all right I
think we're progressing chop chop chop
chop
barry's yes what is this place
isn't this what I was before what hey
I'm feeling oh god damn you Ruben I
don't care if you're not sad all right
at least we got the stuff now top top
top top top top top top top top top
drugs I love drugs makes me I don't
don't do drugs ever softer now that even
if it's free I know it sounds like a
good deal but no I'm not
[ __ ] Ruben yeah what are you died that's
what you get I don't care you can suck
all you want Jesus Christ Ruben I hate
you Ruben I sincerely [ __ ] hate you
alright now we can go Jesus Christ it up
and why would you scare me like that
you are not my dog anymore I don't
appreciate jumping in humping my face go
alright we're progressing section D
let's go this is section D there we go
this is a blue box let's chop it chopped
up top top top top top top top top top
top top top top top top top top top top
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop alright doesn't work
this isn't it yes it was all that room
okay top top top top what is this to do
with this
I don't almost own but wow this is sick
I needed a key for section D and I like
totally got the key for Tekken D but no
no doesn't work
ah dammit I did I what did I do it so
just love this Oh
alright bye bye bye i $99.99 anything my
Harnam thing okay alright alright
wait again let's prank your lap thing
with lasers if I had laser I would try
alright maybe go back
yeah what ah damn it
alright [ __ ] what open nights Reubens
mom she has a really good temper Wow
ow I'm dead are you happy Reubens mom
huh shut up Jesus
Oh Robin it just kills me I don't want
to stand why you would do that
what if I go down here so [ __ ] dark
why was it so dark
ah look jump on stairs it's like the
first lesson you learn in school after
not eating crayons alright let's go back
up the elevator
Jesus Christ now that's stupid monster
is still there da ba ba ba da ba ba da
ha ha ha all right
stop stop stop stop stop stop
ha ha your finger tough huh this isn't
chopper to chop you speak Japanese chop
chop chop it means I like your guts but
I don't like your face because you don't
have one
chop oh you see that you see that I
didn't need to see you I can chop your
anyway [ __ ] alright coming bra wear bra
think you're tough huh you don't know
who you're messing with
you know I am a chop marking chip using
master I invented the Japanese language
that's how tough I am you you don't even
have a head what are you gonna do bad
huh huh huh
chop chop chop ah nice move you killed
me what that I know all right I'll open
it opens mom that's a very poorly place
to say method think about it I want to
save here boom oh there's an outer state
here you know that means cookies and
crayons
mm-hmm it's gotta be something up aa pad
that we go now always works section D
all right I got the key for section D we
open this door somehow the other way
maybe we need this box to get damaged
why did I move it that way let's try
again how to say if there's now to say
they've got to be something like Emma
I'm on the right track
I'm on the right track baby I'm not I'm
not gonna sing Lady Gaga I'm sorry I'm
sorry
all right I don't know why I'm sorry
about that
all right shift to walk slower yes good
no no you're doing it wrong my cell all
up that yeah I had a shot Skinner with
killin I don't know if you can kill box
it's literally but okay second time and
it opens mom I seriously want to kill
room is mom maybe then they stop
spawning peppy awesome all right
quick save all right girl but no all
right let's load one more time
and to fat
stop stop I just want to move you out
alright works doing like that oh cool
alright let's take you out to funk it
down maybe we're supposed to go back or
maybe Reuben is not actually alright I
think this is it this is my intuitions
mr. Platt why are you protecting me
Jesus Christ that we would I thought we
might blast off I don't speak it that
language I only speak Japanese
ok ha ha god damn box why aren't you
cooperating bucks bucks that we got very
nice F [ __ ] six I say jump jump
jump okay F [ __ ] six jump okay
yeah maybe this isn't right after all
huh
now that I think about it it's probably
incorrect hey I take that back it was
just a test you if you were
oh okay look
hello anyone in here oh [ __ ]
okay we're good f6 I'm good okay let's
hello anyone down here
hello look oh I nearly kill myself okay
let's go here start with the flashlight
okay
hello anyone here
wait isn't this where I came from am I
not walking backwards
hello I don't like this place Oh Davis
guys you scare the crap out of me
hey gamba I think she has amo but I have
six health now what am I gonna do anyway
I have to end it here I'm doing the
Lyceum tonight I hope you join link in
the description going to play amnesia
can't stop talking like this like a
favorite I'd really appreciate it
subscribe to him it's become abroad
today and I'll see you at the live
stream hopefully hey y'all happy I am
now
[Music]
this is like yup that monkey fashion
thing if I have figured out to go oh
[ __ ] I thought in this I guess I got
trolled